je vous parle aujourd'hui d'un très
grand téléviseur de LG c'est le 75
qnd86 que je vais prononcer CED mais
dont le nom officiel est prononcé qn d
nouveau modèle de 2023 qui est
extrêmement intéressant pourquoi parce
qu'elle combine plusieurs technologies
dont les technologie propriétaire ici à
LG LG vous le savez c'est un géant de
l'image avec des dalles magnifiques et
ici une télé intéressante c'est
aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est réalisé en
partenariat avec LG je vais donc vous
présenter ce nouveau téléviseur de LG
qu'est-ce qu'on peut venir faire avec
vous allez voir c'est un sujet qui est
vraiment supra cool et d'ailleurs si ce
téléviseur vous intéresse ou si vous
voulez plus d'information bien
évidemment sur ce modèle le CET 86 et
ben bien évidemment je vous mets un lien
juste en bas dans la description je vous
invite à venir cliquer dessus comme ça
vous en saurez davantage sur ce modèle
on se parle ici d'un téléviseur 4K mini
LED qn d c'est une techno réellement
propre à LG je vais vous expliquer ça
dans quelques instants il y a
différentes tailles on se parle ici d'un
téléviseur 75 pouces et 75 pouces c'est
super grand quand je me mets comme ça
voyez j'arrive à toucher les extrémités
bras tendus c'est vraiment hyper grand
comme télé ça va dépendre une fois de
plus de vos besoins de ce dont vous
allez avoir besoin chez vous il existe
des tailles plus petites allez voir une
fois de plus via le lien que je vous
mets juste en bas dans la description
mais si vous voulez un très grand
téléviseur pour du gaming pour regarder
du contenu être en immersion et bien ici
vous avez une diagonale de 189 cm 75
pouces et ça c'est quand même vachement
cool cette télévision elle fait trois
grosses promesses qui sont vraiment
super cool la première c'est d'avoir une
image extrêmement réaliste et quel que
soit l'angle de vision vous allez venir
vous positionner la deuxième c'est
qu'elle est aussi parfaite pour le
gaming donc si vous avez une ps5 une
xbox un PC ou que sais-je encore et bien
vous allez pouvoir vraiment venir vous
amuser dessus sans aucun problème et
puis la troisième bien évidemment on se
parle d'un téléviseur on se parle de
cinéma on se parle d'expérience
immersive pour venir regarder tous vos
contenus alors moi je voudrais qu'on se
parle d'abord la technologie ici d'écran
parce qu'il y a vachement de choses à
dire dessus on se parle d'un LCD QED qnd
mini LED alors LCD vous connaissez je
pense que je vais rien vous apprendre
là-dessus le mini LED c'est vraiment
intéressant c'est une technologie qui se
démocratise de plus en en plus en fait
vous connaissez l'idée de la LED à la
base elle va émettre de la lumière et
l'idée de la mini LED c'est que vous
avez des ledes beaucoup plus petites là
vous allez avoir une LED et bien dans le
même emplacement vous aurez plusieurs
petites ledes cette miniaturisation de
la LED vous permet d'avoir plusieurs
choses déjà de venir jouer sur le détail
parce qu'ell V PIR venir s'allumer
indépendamment les unes des autres donc
beaucoup plus de détail au niveau de
votre image meilleure gestion de la
luminosité meilleure gestion aussi des
couleurs du contrastes des Noirs bref
c'est plein de Bénéfic du fait d'avoir
des mini LED en plus ici on va
travailler sur des zones qui vont venir
sal indépendamment ça va réduire l'effet
de allo et maximiser toujours plus la
qualité de votre image la techno
précision diming precision diming on dit
comme on veut peut-être à l'américaine
precision diming précision diming ici en
français c'est vraiment ce contrôle
ultra précis des zone de l'image pour
avoir un rendu totalement maximisé alors
il y a une autre techno qui est supra
intéressante c'est la techno qned qn d
on appelle ça le cuned c'est une
combinaison de deux technologies
majeures le quantum dot et du nanoell ça
vous permettra d'avoir des noir profond
des contrastes infinis une luminosité
maximale beaucoup plus élevée ça veut
pas dire qu'il faut pousser la
luminosité à fond non mais si vous avez
besoin de pousser un point de plus et
bien grâce à cette techno vous pourrez
le faire de vous à moi laisser la télé
gérer de façon intelligente ça sera ce
qu'il a de mieux ici et puis surtout
vous allez avoir des couleurs très
justes des couleurs intenses et ça c'est
aussi un point extrêmement important
tout ça magnifié avec de l'intelligence
artificielle grâce au processeur alpha 7
ai 4K gen 6 en fait qu'est-ce que va
venir faire le processeur derrière il a
une technologie d'apprentissage profond
et il va venir ajuster l'image pour
avoir un rendu totalement optimisé en
fait vous avez de l'a qui va venir
reconnaître les différents éléments sur
votre téléviseur et qui va vraiment
faire un travail d'optimisation aussi
bien de l'image mais aussi du son mais
le son on en parle dans quelques
instants et puis il y a un autre point
qui est super intéressant c'est qu'ici
vous avez plus d'un million de nuances
de gris qui fait que vous avez une image
qui est 64 fois beaucoup plus précise
que ce qu'on pouvait connaître avant et
ça même et surtout dans les zones
d'ombre et ça c'est vraiment important
regardez les angles de vision c'est
aussi super bon donc pas besoin de se
mettre en face vous pouvez venir vous
décaler vous décaler sur le côté vous
aurez toujours de bons angles de vision
ça c'est quand même vachement bien ça
vous permet de profiter de votre contenu
ù vous voulez quelle que soit votre
position très facilement et ça une fois
de plus c'est vachement cool et on se
parle d'angles de vision qui vont
jusqu'à 120° donc vous pouvez vraiment
venir vous mettre sur le côté pas de
problème ça marche bien alors LG nous
fait une autre promesse ici c'est le
fait de pouvoir utiliser sa télévision
CED qnd pour l'expérience gaming ça
c'est aussi important parce que c'est
vraiment un usage qu'on a de plus en
plus on joue de plus en plus et on aime
jouer sur des grands écrans alors là une
fois de plus en 75 pouces je peux vous
assurer que sont des parties de ce que
vous voulez vous allez vraiment être en
immersion mais une fois de plus il
existe également différentses tailles
peut-être que 75 pouces c'est trop petit
ou trop grand pour chez vous allez jeter
un coup d'œil pour trouver la taille qui
vous convient une fois de plus je vous
mets le lien juste en bas dans la
description l'idée d'une télévision en
gaming et bien c'est pas juste d'allumer
pas vous jouer ça non ce qui est
intéressant c'est que vous avez un mode
jeu un mode jeu spécialisé qui permettra
d'avoir une image qui est totalement
optimisée et ben oui forcément en plus
de ça vous avez un tableau de bord avec
des paramétrages qui vont être faciles
clair liisible en plus vous pouvez venir
changer je de mode jeu parce que tous
les jeux ne sont pas les mêmes il y a
une différence entre un jeu de course un
jeu de shoot et compagnie bref vous
aurez pas forcément besoin des mêmes
réglages vous pouvez donc venir choisir
entre le mode sport le mode FPS le mode
RTS et j'en passe des meilleurs si bien
que tous les joueurs pourront venir
trouver ici leur bonheur sans aucun
problème ça va jouer également sur les
paramètres du son ça c'est aussi très
cool et vous pouvez faire le choix
d'activer ou désactiver le free 5 comme
ça pas de déchirement d'image en
fonction une fois de plus des jeux que
vous allez utiliser ça vous apportera
beaucoup plus de fluidité avec le free 5
que si vous ne mettiez pas le free 5
vous allez venir jouer ici jusqu'à 4K
120 images par seconde donc ça c'est
vachement cool en terme de fluidité on
se parle ici d'une expérience
d'olbyision HDR 4K 1220 vous avez une
faible latence avec la LM low latency
donc faible latence également l'arc et
au dos vous allez trouver deux ports
HDMI 2.1 donc si vous avez deux consoles
à venir brancher pas besoin d'en
débrancher une pour en brancher une
autre avec un seul port non vous pouvez
venir brancher ici un PC une console ce
que vous voulez c'est très pratique et
si vous n'avez pas de console pouvez
venir jouer dans le Cloud ce qu'on
appelle du cloud gaming grâce à Nvidia
jeforce Nao et grâce au HG et bien vous
pouvez jouer à des jeux HDR qui vont
vous couper le souffle et ça c'est
vachement cool vous avez énormément de
jeux sur jeforce Nao de la simulation
vous avez plein de jeux des jeux de
shoot des jeux de Square ENX il y en a
tous les côtés il y a énormément de gens
des jeux d'action de l'aventure de
l'arcade cojol familial jeu de combat
bref il y en a pour tout le monde et ça
c'est quand même vachement bien et
lorsque vous avez branché une console et
bien vous avez ici l'option optimiseur
de jeu vous allez avoir plein d'options
intéressantes on va venir activer ici
l'optimiseur de jeu avec un tableau de
bord jeu le vrr le variable refresh rate
la MD free 5 premium qu'on peut venir
activer ou désactiver on va se le mettre
ici à élever on peut venir personnaliser
jusque dans les couleurs de menu le
violet le orange le vert le violet me va
bien le guide utilisateur et après vous
verrez votre FPS ici votre vrr la
balance des noir faible latence des
options d'image également on vient
régler ici tout la balance des Noirs le
contraste du jeu bref on peut venir
faire tout et ça c'est vachement cool
même votre format là c'est du 169
également au niveau du son le Dolby
Atmos qui est activé par défaut la
sortie bref vous avez vachement
d'options ça c'est très très bien côté
design on a un écran qui est aussi super
beau et super fin et moi ce que j'adore
vraiment c'est ce pied central que vous
avez là qui vous permet de poser sur
n'importe quel meuble alors moi c'est
pas trop meuble forcément adapté il est
assez petit par rapport à la taille du
téléviseur mais ce qui est génial c'est
que quel que soit votre meuble et bien
ici avec le nouveau pied central vous
n'aurez absolument aucun problème autre
élément qui est super bien c'est la
finesse qu'on va venir retrouver ici
c'est une télé qui est quand même super
fine et puis autre élément qui est
important vous avez un passage de câble
qui se fait ici par le pied central donc
il y a rien qui va traîner on a donc un
super design des bords ultra fin et ça
franchement j'adore gros partenariat qui
a apporté LG dans ce téléviseur c'est le
partenariat avec Dolby dolby sur la
partie image Dolby vision sur la partie
audio Dolby Atmos qui est super
intéressant du fait de venir retrouver
les technologies Dolby ici notamment sur
Dolby vision et bien c'est que vous
allez avoir une image qui va être très
proche de l'image souhaitée par le
réalisateur de la même manière ici le
son n'est pas en reste vous allez avoir
du 40 W en de fois de canal et du Son
DTSX côté logiciel on a une expérience
qui est quand même vachement cool avec
sinkq Web OS elle est extrêmement facile
à utiliser vous arrivez sur votre écran
d'accueil depuis votre écran d'accue
accueil vous avez des options assez
intéressantes au niveau du télétravail
pour travailler sur un grand écran la
partie jeu la partie musique le tableau
de bord de la maison du sport bref il y
a vachement de choses vous avez en
dessous vos applications il y en a
énormément peut venir en télécharger
énormément également puis vous retrouvez
les tendances actuelles au niveau des
films des séries les chaînne LG bref
tout est là c'est intéressant Apple TV
Disney plus racuten TV YouTube prime
vidéo j'en passe c'est des meilleurs on
a les nouvelles sorties les films
populaire bref il y en a énormément et
ça c'est quand même vachement cool on va
vous trouver vos notifications vos
réglages votre recherche bref tout est
apporté de clic et ça c'est vachement
intuitif on a en plus ici la epcture
Wizard qui va analyser jusà 85 millions
de configurations potentielles pour
trouver l'image qui vous conviendra le
mieux et une fois de plus personnaliser
totalement l'expérience sur ce
téléviseur autre point qui est
intéressant c'est la télécommande
magique on a une grande télécommande
avec plein de boutons ça on en a besoin
forcément des chiffres réglag de volume
des petites options ça c'est vraiment un
côté magique je vais vous montrer dans
quelques instants et puis des raccourcis
Netflix Disney plus prime vidéo recuten
TV les chaînes LG puis Alexa bien
évidemment et le truc qui est vraiment
cool c'est que vous pouvez effectivement
naviguer à droite à gauche ça va venir
moduler directement mais vous avez aussi
une option qui est très cool et que moi
j'adore sur les tvlg c'est qu'en fait
vous avez un petit pointeur derrière
voyez qui se déplace et qui va suivre
vos mouvements donc c'est un peu comme
une espèce de souris et c'est ça le côté
un peu magique de cette télécommande
c'est que en fonction des déplacements
que vous allez avoir et bien vous allez
vous retrouver avec votre pointeur
magique vous allez naviguer donc il y a
un côté un peu marrant on a plein de
façons de fonctionner soit en vous
déplaçant à droite à gauche soit en
bougeant votre télécommande dans tous
les cas vous avez énormément de
possibilités énormément de boutons elle
tient bien en main donc ça une fois de
plus c'est aussi très pratique comme on
parle ici d'une Smart TV on parle d'une
télé connectée elle est ici compatible
mateur donc vous allez pouvoir venir
piloter la domotique à la maison très
facilement ici donc ça c'est vachement
bien en plus de ça on va venir retrouver
Alexa pour avoir plein d'infos
intelligent piloter vos appareils
compatibles à la maison donc une fois de
plus c'est super cool bref cette
nouvelle télé elle a vachement
d'avantage au niveau de l'image elle est
vraiment bien au niveau de l'expérience
de gaming elle est top au niveau de
l'audio elle fonctionne bien on a donc
une expérience globale qui est très cool
et une fois de plus ça dépend de la
taille que vous voulez 75 15 pouces ici
c'est énorme mais on peut avoir plus
petit bien évidemment c'est un peu grand
pour chez moi je vous le montre ici le
75 pouces un 55 65 aurait été un peu
mieux mais une fois de plus ça dépend
des intérieurs on n pas tous les mêmes
tailles si vous avez un peu de recul que
vous avez un grand espace pour mettre
votre téléviseur et bien 65 pouces ça
peut être très cool il existe des
tailles aussi plus grandes chez LG ce
que je vous invite à faire c'est venir
cliquer sur le lien que vous avez en bas
dans la description comme ça vous saurez
tout sur votre téléviseur de LG ça c'est
vachement cool et puis n'hésitez pas à
me dire vous en commentaire ce que vous
en pensez si vous avez des questions des
interrogations sur ce modè vous marquez
tout ça bien évidemment juste en bas
dans les commentaires j'espère que ce
téléviseur vous aura intéressé merci LG
d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo puis nous
on se retrouve très bientôt pour
continuer à parler et croyez-moi
croyez-moi il y a vachement de choses
qui arrivve et ça c'est une très bonne
nouvelle